[Musik]
sie bat selber
da wenig stoff denen ist die heimische
bahn muss er machen sind nach emden wo
verträge melatonin tabletten das leben
und die jugendlichen wieder absetzen was
hilft und was heilt im leben und zu
welchem preis
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
hätte ich gesagt dass sie die haare hier
ist die jene die sie für die bereich ist
in dieser werner apotheke hängt keine
werbung hier hängt kunst silvio
berlinale hat seine eigenen
vorstellungen hausapotheke stoffe zu
verzichten sie ihren konsum von
medikamentes problem ganz generell ist
nicht irgendwelchen konsum war und
ethisch weniger und umgekehrt also
selber kessing damit möglichst viel
medikamente mit möglichst kleinen stadt
biel hingegen hals und kopfschmerzen
bilder von migranten und migrantinnen
hergestellt mit einer motorsäge
für silvio berlin ari steht der mensch
im zentrum die patienten statt der
profit die apotheke trägt deshalb auch
seine handschrift
ja das ist spaß macht und ich glaube die
kommune und dem handy führen ist er seit
ich sachen machen
silvio berlin er sei ein vorbild gar ein
vollendeter humanist das sagt der
generalsekretär des schweizer
apothekerverbands pharmasuisse über den
berner ein apotheker der für ein
gerechteres gesundheitssystem kämpft so
ehrlich schaffen und um verdiente es
schaffe für patienten und denkbar lüth
tasche vor einer industrie wo ein flug
das maximum für jerry hall user konkret
und das regt mich wirklich oft wie sie
verschmutzen eigentlich zu vertrauen zu
haben ist vom ganze gesundheitsweisen
schweiz das erfolgte sagte ja wohl gar
nicht schlecht
das ist vom tisch das stimmt nicht steht
aus vom tiefen war vorbei kommt es ist
großartig aber wenn das maximum was user
unabhängig davon dass das vielleicht
patient für eine ganze patient der
gruppe getötet
denn ist es schlimm besonders aufgeregt
hatte sich vor ein paar jahren über eine
amerikanische pharma firma die einen
alten wirkstoff als teures medikament
verkauft die substanz dimethylfumarat
soll bei multiple sklerose helfen weil
die na'vi zeigte wir ein mittel mit
gleichem wirkstoff herstellt er verkauft
diesen zehn mal günstiger ein kleiner
umtriebiger apotheker der das große
geschäft der pharmaindustrie entlarvt
das sorgte für kontroversen sogar im
nationalrat war davon die rede
klebstoffe schmackes auf der sich dann
mit ihrer show mehrere jahre war ich mit
mit der patientin thomas cueni
geschäftsführer vom branchenverband
interpharma krankenkassen prämien
stiegen ständig und jetzt
mit dem medikament kommen wir aber die
kosten aus stücken bestand wir sind sie
da auch dafür wenn ich der apotheker
angelockt wer nur im hinterzimmer
vorhand die tablette macht keinen sinn
wenn drei lüth frauen oder männern
kirche machen mit dem gleichen rezept
und die enten gibt es trotzdem treffen
steht nicht schmeckt griechische medien
die website hat sie verschreibt die art
von medikament die apotheke medikamente
regelmäßig sie hatten am ersten kann das
ist und julia servicezeit worten keine
daten über sicherheit und wirksamkeit
von dem apotheker produkte studie
gemacht
bedingungen die sie also tadellos
es ist natürlich nicht irgendwelche
hinterhof hey ich werde kontrolliert da
kommt kantonsapotheker haare und wirkt
wie mich schaffen und somit die poesie
apotheke hier dass sie nicht
irgendwelche abstellte und die wissen
was sie heißt eu und die idee die die
produkt wird vom industrie was soko taxi
heim ist vom aktiven sie verunreinigt
sie zum beispiel mit nitrosaminen
kapazitäten teenager das herstellen von
heimischen
das ist seine mission silvio berlinale
will diese kernkompetenz der apotheker
wieder stärken
dazu brauche es aber auch ärzte die
nicht nur medikamenten marken auf das
rezept schreiben sondern einzelne
substanzen assoziiert mit quax
eigentlich da wo der liter bis vollmacht
und zeigt dass ich den kurs und im
grunde ist es aber völlig normal als
placebo
aber bis das der trainingswoche nicht
verpackt und zur sache macht oder der
pharmaindustrie ist wo nicht die ganze
studie publiziert damit sie raus rufe
und so menschenleben in gefahr bringen
also dass sie quasi selber
er nimmt uns mit in die vergangenheit
apotheker müssen jede substanz jedes
mittel sorgfältig dokumentieren
[Musik]
der sekretär bücher von 1906 bis heute
durchgehend alles da sind digitaluhr da
ich heute noch so er dirigierte gehabt
hätten und die patienten einmal 60 und
pries die rezeptur und da jetzt gleich
erhöht da nur die gesetzeshüter society
zum start zu schaffen haben wir das
zurückverfolgen
also jetzt ist die hsg fünftletzten
rückverfolgbar sie es geht natürlich
ebenso schöne wie zb gesunden ordne die
apotheke hat eine langjährige geschichte
es ist auch die seiner vorfahren denn
silvio berlinale hat den beruf von
seinen eltern geerbt
[Musik]
einfach das kann een et ass das ist
schon klar emotionell das brauche ich
natürlich nicht
tron carbon rundschau tätig kette vom
krisen immer vom begründer vorjahr pro
tag also das ist seit 130 jahren in der
berner länggasse die zähringer apotheke
ist die älteste quartier apotheke der
stadt bern vater berlinale hier mit sohn
silvio übernimmt sie 1944 die mutter
neuenburgerin der vater tessiner zwei
von vier kindern werden später selbst
apotheker
vater und sohn teilen den beruf doch
nicht die überzeugung sein vater habe
der pharma industrie noch sehr vertraut
das ist auch die die medikament geht und
so und hätten die schlacht in england
allerdings sondern zu einer anderen zeit
wo mit je 12 1981 übernimmt silvio
berlin ari das geschäft von seinen
eltern zusammen mit seiner damaligen
frau ja das gp umso apotheke basics zeit
nicht so ganz weg das wird ihm zahlen
das war mich macht es insofern sehr
interessant 7 wenn sie ihr kind
adoptiert mehr hier genau heftig dass
dabei geht also nach vierter tag ist
eine high gegangen und hat sogar
fankultur verträgt kann man hat immer
gewusst was der andere macht was für
eine pci belastende svenja mit den
anderen sehr viel zeit genommen
beides gleich machen
[Musik]
dabei ist er einer der viel zu sagen hat
weil ihn viel interessiert er ist nicht
nur apotheker sondern auch künstler
philosoph musiker ein buntes leben das
nicht immer in geraden bahnen verläuft
kommt er hier ankommt er zur ruhe
das atelier seines argentinischen
künstlerfreundes ist für den apotheker
ein ort der inspiration
er malt oft heute sind es etiketten für
produkte in seiner apotheke dieser seite
der apotheke wartung bis kreativ was
macht frau das hat das ministeramt war
für diese prüft sei es mir wie weiter
zum teil gar nicht richtig warm und und
ohne zurück die ganz genau und wenn wie
bisher muss man auch dafür bis
machtgefühl silvio bei den arri macht
viel im leben und das mit leidenschaft
bis er selber risiken und nebenwirkungen
spürt das war vor sieben jahren
ausgesehen haben wir durch herzinfarkt
ich sehen würde dass sie die die
heizkörper und rohre verstopft und darf
sondern wahnsinnig die wirkliche
vertrauens körper und da schlägt manager
habe schon einen hypochonder jetzt an
ihn oder sie stars und so ab jetzt
vielleicht doch lyon kann identität und
wir feiern hier aber diesmal mit
technologischer beglichen ist nicht gut
und bedieneinheit zum doktor ist
denkt sofort gemacht und sofort ins
spital
er hat glück aber nicht immer 2018
erkrankt seine langjährige
lebenspartnerin schwer wird die saison
definitiv ist der andere siebten absatz
aber meistens krank und muss liter das
ist mir persönlich eigentlich schlimme
denkt also die ziele wie sie in amerika
recht stufenweise theologisches kam und
das ist schlimm
was hilft und was heilt im leben das
weiß auch ein apotheker nicht immer
[Musik]
stähli cato setzte sich außerdem einig
dieses niveau fatalistisch sie es gilt
also wenn man dank wie banal des hauses
wo man ihm du hast du denn gesund machen
das stimmte zehnfache regionen mit oder
beziehen
und das bewegt im körper bis wort körper
nach wie vor sich sie natürlich für die
lebenskraft wen du sax und weiter er
selbst hat seine lebensenergie wieder
gefunden eine neue liebe kann heilsam
sein wird wo vielleicht nicht lang
abgang einbinden und so vielleicht
schlitzwände landrut das stimmt sondern
entweder fördergeld und das hat nicht
viel druck gemacht haben ich begann sich
das wenn wenn wenn nicht sie könnte
mitbestimmen der entführer wenn wenn es
mit geld aus umgekehrt sie über die
nahrung ist kein kind von traurigkeit
einige wochen bevor corona das
zusammensein verändert lädt er mit
seiner band zum tanz der alt-68er glaubt
an den wirkstoff musik musik ist heilsam
für dir was macht und wenn natürlich
begegnen und so eine ganze liste samt
[Musik]
er hat in den 70er jahren das
folkfestival ins burg organisiert einen
vorläufer des heutigen gurtenfestivals
[Musik]
die band tutti frutti spielzeit fast 40
jahren zusammen
jahrelang war auch bei die nares
lebenspartnerin als musikerin dabei
[Musik]
heute verlost heute kommen auch seine
neue partnerin und seine tochter
frauen
ich kenne natürlich arena dafür kriegen
dass er musik macht dafür was ich sie
und weil ich das stück sie gegen
arbeiterklasse der familie festnahme
gemacht hat nach einem kleineren raum
maxi und aber ein geständnis sich und ja
und man erkennt und täglich na das sind
elemente
[Musik]
liga
ciani teufel
[Musik]
pauli ist klar ich muss es so sagen ich
bin dafür ist im familiären rahmen der
inzwischen zur hälfte bin ich weniger
buchbacher liebe vorstellt rücksitz saß
dachte der epcos kein auge mehr hoffen
natürlich fehlt auch immer sie
[Musik]
mit filmen
[Applaus]
es ist märz 2020 ein frühling für die
geschichtsbücher
die schweizerinnen und schweizer decken
sich millionenfach mit medikamenten 1
gegen kuwait 19 gehen in diesem monat 40
prozent mehr medikamentenpackungen in
apotheken über den ladentisch als im
märz vor einem jahr
seine gemalte etikette ist fertig
geworden für einen anti viralen t
passend zur corona zeit und jetzt
braucht die party für sie vier euro das
stück
29 jaja ich alles kann gleichfalls hat
jetzt schon den markt massiv laufen
damit mitglieder hoffen
das ist wirklich das ganze konzert ampel
ist nicht schlecht
schickte dafür eine maske pflicht
epigone pflicht wenn er wenn
verpflichtet weder bismarck ist
garantiert nimmt aber einig dass die
maßnahme motor verwaltet sofort die
strecke vom bundesrat finde ich ganz gut
ich will so richtig dass man jene
maßnahmen entlud dass gesundheit von der
note sehr gut geschützt ist aus das
zweite findet das richtig und das müssen
mediziner haushalte während man sich
drinnen auf eine extreme situation
einstellt ist draußen im garten der
apotheke von hektik nichts zu spüren
diese schildkröten beenden ihre
winterruhe
marina riss nichten helfen mit sie zu
wecken ist kamelle nächstes schweiz
camilla sand und der wasserrinne da und
das ist auch gut tut man ja auch
verwahrte und so das cool ja klar
sie schwimmt nicht wenn das fröhliche
treiben tag hört sich für mich über 70
jahre alt sind manche dieser tiere 1944
kaufte vater war die na'vi drei
griechische landschildkröten dafür hat
das wesen und von den heads up grunde
sieht damit den talking heads and
ownership mitten in oslo kauft und das
ist das ende der tour und die worte so
dass die partie praktisch sie und der
rückseite wir so etwas machen wir euch
die ekz langheim mit frühstück man
dachte dass der fußball als verrucht die
haut der partie eigentlich verschenkt
und es ist ein die glut auch heute kann
also jetzt fertig mit zu schenken
das ist heute bis einschlägigen man sei
die heutige techno entschleunigen das
macht silvio berlinerin nun nach und
nach auch in der kleinen apotheke
14 personen arbeiten in seinem geschäft
wenn ich verstehe meine letzte stelle
konzentriert und müsse das könne wo die
fetten apotheke also die qualität im
schnitt zwar ist die qualität ist das
für mich machen und das war ein kämpfer
das ist es der mensch im zentrum
das bedeutet für den idealisten marinade
auch dass er als arbeitgeber ein zeichen
setzen will und asylbewerberinnen eine
chance gibt mit dohmen der schweiz
schweizer in landes vorrang wenn man
sagt das ist der tod das eine
beleidigung als mensch sie soll ist dass
wir den enten nummer wie sie ältere
ganze nicht die gleiche chance geht wir
pro stelle sie die einzig das ist jetzt
weltweit um heim und die fahrer geschaut
die dass sie ja mit seiner browser
machen und sie tut sich einander bis
zeigen genau richtig sie hätten einander
nicht gefehlt um das ist dass diese
qualität ist also mit profitieren auch
davor dass mit evt die heime absagte
hatte keine chance
ja du hast ja zu diesem zeitpunkt war
die junge syrerin in der schweiz bloss
vorläufig aufgenommen das ist so sicher
das ist jetzt so und
beim wettbewerb wo es plötzlich
negativen entscheid schon sie wie schon
die troja da sie und da muss ein starker
widerstand leisten alternativen bieten
das will auch als pharmakritische
apotheker ein befreundeter botaniker
möchte ich wirklich gut neu hier stellen
ein altes fast vergessenes aller welt
mittel aus dem emmental
das fasziniert mich das pflanzloch
wusste aus der neue bücher musik
november sitzt erhöht und es viel später
festgestellt dass das aber gleich nützt
jetzt natürlich die die wahl setzt schon
bewiesen dass es heute gut was wirklich
nehmen
ganz knapp dahinter das kennt street wo
der studie und die zahlen aber verrät es
muss mir das sicher für birte nummer
wohnsitz nicht aus medikament zugleich
[Musik]
also dass da hier ist die erste
schweizer skifirma cottbus ots die sind
von kampfbombern den damen nancys von
852 haben erklärt dass wenn das
flutwasser sonne tradition hat der muss
das logische wie sorry telefon sie
wenn's der euro wirklich medizinische
gesetz droht ist was tatsächlich drin
das heißt das hat man im nu seite
erholte dorf verbandes die bruder
gestorben
noch heute pflanzen emmentaler bauern
wirklich gut an
alina reh soll für den botaniker
überprüfen ob das daraus gewonnene
aromatische wasser gesundheitlich
unbedenklich ist die pflanze holt er bei
einem biobauern du stehst du auch
wirklich zu trinken
seit dezember hunderte wurde da kein
zugute
es ist ich habe nur interessant
schulmedizinisch tut mir ja blut nehmen
selbst die volksmedizin ist eine firma
aus blutreinigung das ist das gibt's
kein blut gereinigt das mit der krieg
aber zu tun haben
und dann nimmt man die relativ
wehrführer tisch nehmen so aspirin und
sowohl für dunja instrument stattdessen
einfach körperlich gut wasser würden
stadtteils war natürlich schon erhält
das kraut lassen der botaniker und der
apotheker bei einem bauern destillieren
das sehen wir heute 2008 wurde und unter
den pinien ausgang eicher multitasking
massig oder am 8 januar medizinstandort
und mit tutti frutti annette einige
konzerte erleben oder und dann nämlich
ein rennen wie eine apotheke gesucht
haben wo eigentlich quasi wird die
wissenschaftliche sehr gut auf das möbel
kultur
die frisch geschnittenen stauden 7 im
wasserdampf des brennofens das
alkoholfreie kondensationswärme hlt sich
und tröpfelt stunden später durch die
rohre in den behälter
noch schmeckt das wirklich gut wasser er
nach schlechtem pastis
[Musik]
neben und nach heraus stechen jetzt
sicher ausmachen stift windows kopien
wie die mine krise ist eine beziehung
technologisch setzt das für ihn also und
den proben so und so und je nach termin
mit fünf jahren zum abitur führt jedem
des stoffes gesund machen
die aktion und die stoffe wo wohnen
verändert ich bringe ihnen begegnet wenn
man verliebt ist
diese zwinge dazu gemacht dass der
körperliche reaktion
das kann man das kann man wirklich auch
chemische und physikalische griechisches
molekül übergegangen es ist nun
vergangen sehr viele rät sie es ist
nicht melodie wo ich gesund macht und
melodie womit höhere macht der süßen
schwingt sie das veränderte team könnte
das ist entscheidend
[Musik]
was hilft und was halt im leben diese
apotheker würde sagen es ist nicht bloß
das mittel sondern auch das was wir im
leben darum machen
[Musik]